I read this really funny story about
your daughter loving Matt Damon and the
marshes and love are you gonna hook that
up surprised well she asked me if I
would ask him to come to her birthday
party and I said no I'm thinking I'll
get her a Matt Damon poster
she made me Google Matt Damon dolls that
was disturbing when it comes to Pink's
own celeb obsession it's all day all day
we talked about the latex dress do we
want to talk about how much she was
probably sweating um she's incredible I
think I think she's just up here she's
in a league of her own just like
Pink's lighting up the film world for
the first time her track just like fire
was written for Johnny Depp's latest
Alice Through the Looking one and being
that it's Disney does this score you
cool mom points I hope so
cuz I don't have that money right now no
no why not he just thinks I'm a total
dork
what thinks my voice is distracted she
said I love you mom but you're very
disappointed
does she have musical prowess are you
seeing that develop ever she is she's
pitch perfect and she's loud what are
you doing to kind of nurture that gift
in her I just let her be free in wild I
just have loved watching the world
through her eyes she's completely
unshaded unstained she's just amazing
Mother's Day is this weekend good glad I
hope I have plans I'm just lucky to be a
momma my prize is her so I'm happy and I
get to tell my mom I love her